[Music]
please welcome my friend Martin Lawrence
[Applause]
[Applause]
to the audience you always and you send
it I loved I didn't I've been in show
business a while I never knew that one
yeah you got nice slam but thank you
I'll get it
yeah that seems like you're sending the
kiss too fast cut into him like a ninja
blade it also seems like you're making
it rain I love that that's nice I'm
gonna use that from now now it's all
right okay I said this to you backstage
you look you always look good but you
you look like you've been really taking
care of yourself I don't know what
you're doing what's the difference here
crap it's very very good as a weight
loss I'm just working out exercising
every now and then you know every other
of other day and just eat joint you're
doing it everything it was there
something that motivated you to do that
get my blood pressure down it doctor
said my blood I said I can't have that
so but I still got the gut though I
still got all this look like pudding
right now how buff I get that's what
that's the thing that men have that
problem sometimes is you know you get to
certain agent no matter what you do
you're gonna have something there
there's no way and you know but it's
good you know give your lady something
to hold on make it even Pat it yeah they
could just Pat it really nice I like to
tuck things in their little snacks and
things I can find later got a Oreo
Hummel figurine oh isn't he cute that
sort of thing now okay what is your
technique what do you do in the gym I'm
just curious
I'll get crazy because some people get
intense do you where I sometimes I see
people running in like a suit that they
sweat oh no I don't do that no more I
did that and I went into a coma and
passed out so please
I recommend do not run the plastic suit
do you not do that I know that you did
that yeah you did that back in the day
and that was the problem was yeah I was
trying to lose weight and I you know I
my training I used to box so that's
that's how I trained so running and
wearing plastic and I just picked the
hottest day of the summer next thing I
know I'll sleep alright
all right yeah and so you said you were
boxing - do you still box
I don't box I just train I either train
a little bit yeah hand still sharp don't
get it wrong close it you you want I'll
go I you look out for me because I'm
fast I gotta what note your thing is
that what I have to do is I like to talk
my opponent with my big fat head all
right it's coming around like a parade
fellow I'm gonna buy out but then this
comes up okay then you knock that out of
the way and then you beat the [ __ ] out
of ya or one of his favorite techniques
as I hit you with a shoe yeah it's just
Juna I heard a rumor that because people
have those bad boys movies 1 & 2 that
there's gonna be a bad boys 3 is that
possible I believe so yes I just talked
to Jared I just [ __ ] the jury
yesterday and he said is really they're
working on the script again closing us
it all looks good now have you done all
the casting on that yet no we won't cast
you in it I would love to be in a bad
boys movie I think know what you could
play
what's that is a crooked cop on crack
yes
I don't know where the money is it's
just missing like that that too much
that's probably too much for film I
don't know Andy you know more about
actually that would be good if it was
1936
that's my acting style it's a little bit
over the top you want to make me a
promise that I'll East have a cameo like
if I could walk buying a scene well I
will mention it to Will Smith and Jerry
Bruckheimer onin wants a cameo in the
more place in Germany in show business
that's called a No
you